you got to wake up you got to drive you
got to be driven to to go get something
done now never comes free
nobody's gonna give anybody anything I
like being able to do what I to do what
I love doing for a living
here's an American hip hop recording
artist and actor he's released nine
studio albums with seven of them
reaching the top five on the Billboard
charts
he's Ti and here's my take on his top
ten role for success tip you're an ant
man I got just watched me and the kids
just watch doing it man what you doing
over there
I still full up in the days I booed at
the house by the blue eyes all the time
and I mean that's just because that is
the source of my inspiration right I
mean they keeps you in touch that's what
I draw from you know this music this
thing of ours came from that element
after lutely so as you just said how
could I even expect to be in the mindset
if I just was beat-up sailing on the
French Riviera you know saying somewhere
in a penthouse in Malibu or excuse me
beach house in a beach house in Malibu
somewhere I mean I could make some kind
of music but it was a nice house by the
way oh absolutely I enjoyed those tops
absolutely but you ballad you do you do
you need a Bal you need to pull off from
over there and go somewhere that'll show
you why you appreciate being here right
you know me and if you lose touch of
that if you don't have that the anchor
to keep you grounded somewhat then you
think it it's like this all the time and
it's gonna always be like this this is
just what life is like and it gives you
a distorted vision of reality so I like
to keep myself grounded and connected to
what I know it is real it was real is
[ __ ] you have up you gonna end up right
back as a aspiring entrepreneur um you
know I noticed you've done a lot of
things I don't want to go along with
your credentials I know we know that
what do you do you know what takes what
did it take for you to build your empire
man it took man it took execution time
at the time at the time you know a
proper execution in many different areas
in consistency
it took resilience and you know you just
have to show up and show out so often
right on time out of the time you got to
wake up you got to drive you got to be
driven to to go get something done now
you know that and you I'm in for really
and it's a gamble sometimes you gotta
really really you got to be forward
thinking ahead of the curve when it
comes time to make certain decisions and
you got to be willing to stand on your
stand on yo yo beliefs
cuz a lot of times you don't only want
who to see it you did other people they
don't see it really but you got to
really believe in what you got inside of
you is telling you and driving you to a
certain goal for something I can do yeah
I was challenged by my my manager right
now a producer DJ tune and my cousin who
passed away they challenged me how long
whoa
this was about 12 13 years ago 98 he was
17 8 17 18 and they challenged me to a
stop selling drugs stop selling Craigie
they say you want to be a rap but this
is what you want to do
you've already been arrested you've
already gotten you did just just look at
the time you got probation if you get
arrested again you blow it all so I
didn't said okay we'll take me somewhere
where I can I can create a way for
myself if you want me to leave this
behind then make make make up making
show me an opportunity they then took me
to the studio with a group named pa pa
then put me on the spot asked me if I
could rap on a certain date I walked in
the booth
did my thing and they signed me to
LaFace records I'm old-time man most
celebrities are artists I seen a common
gold man all the time and they they
really think that it's about them hmm
yeah I mean they think that oh yeah
people just love like me is it's about
me and really it's about what you what
you do the service that you can provide
as you're like man how much would you
appreciate your dentists if you've got
your teeth and how much would you
appreciate your mechanic if he didn't
fix your car right you know they're long
is the service that you provide is that
of a stellar quality above a boss
standards then you're gonna appreciate
the person holding my high regard when
that service begins to diminish then
you're going you not gonna hold a person
to have a go at normal and that why you
see people come and go so fast when they
get that they forget that it's about the
quality of what they can present the
quality of the the you know the work
that they can provide to the people and
when they stop providing that quality of
work or they feel they don't have to
they feel they a too big they feel you
know entitled hey man that when they
disappear nobody's gonna get any bag
anything now you get out of life
to hard work sacrifice dedication all
these things
breathe success now I can tell you this
because you know I was once one of the
people who were assumed to be less
likely to become successful I'm from a
very modest neighborhood I did you know
I did you necessarily grow up with a
silver spoon in my mouth I don't have
all things that I wanted sometimes not
even all the things that I need but it's
important for you to know your
environment does not define you unless
you allow it to the positions your hand
right now the position you're here right
now does not dictate your future unless
you allow it to you can look at your
life as it is right now that you can
look at it you can say well I'm not
wearing it so isn't what my life will
need you can do one or two things you
could use it as an excuse to do method
or you can use it as motivation to push
yourself all the choice is yours
I need you guys to understand and
believe that anything in life is
possible whatever it is you want to do
is absolutely possible I don't care I'm
going to trouble you've gotten into up
until now I don't care how many things
you may have done wrong I don't care how
much you may not have in your life to
help you you can do it if you believe in
yourself enough to make it happen
if you put enough if you put enough
effort and energy and invest for nothing
you can do anything in this world you
want to do anything is possible don't
never let nobody tell you what you can't
do I started rapping when I was nine
years old nine years old and I'm from
Atlanta so every time I'm not affected
that wasn't no other rappers in Atlanta
and I heard everything scuse why I
couldn't be a rapper I heard every
excuse why I couldn't be famous
everything from you can't grab you too
skinny you know everything from don't
nobody from the South maybe go platinum
I heard all these things a whole bunch
of excuses a whole bunch of reasons why
I should not believe that I could make
it but my belief my belief over Canada
that doubt because I believe in myself
and if I can do it whatever it is that I
have done you can do it uh I'm trying to
stay honest you know some brilliant got
to try man like I'll have no choice you
know I'm saying like it won't even come
out my mouth forfeiting if it ain't true
like it if it ain't something that I
really live in a way that I really feel
something I'm really going through I
won't even allow myself to say it you
know it's like as I'm putting it
together like I never said it you know
say like it don't even register if it
ain't if it ain't authentic didn't like
being famous to be the best I don't
really know not really famous I like I
like being able to do what I to do what
I love doing for a living you know your
papers dudes ya get paid for doing
something I love I enjoyed that your
fame just happens to be something that
comes with it that I look at it as right
I look at it as more of a detriment than
you know that a benefit to me we're
blessed to be paid for something yellow
we're blessed and we don't you know to
enjoy what we do the state of saying
means to receive the same Wow in order
to grow it in order to
to reach new levels of success you got
to put yourself in a position to be
eligible for these new levels of success
nothing worth having comes without hard
work and sacrifice you go out the
struggle you're gonna have to
show how much you wanted show is worth
to you know there have been times we
have made it difficult for me but
there's also been times made it easier
for me this is a cliche question but
what do you see yourself in 10 years 15
years hard to say really
yeah I mean you know 10 15 years ago I
didn't see myself here
why so it's hard to say I just hope to
take advantage of my opportunities and
reach my full potential
I to continue to have an impact on my
sons and my daughter's lives I mean she
continued to make my mama happy Wow
and create new standards of living for
my family
cultivate the artists of young talent
with as much or more potential as me I
doubt we'll see that too now you know
that will see another ti
never now I know the ti you might see
another ITT buddies in sawmills you know
ti ends by way of river but you know I
just want a man I want to live I want to
continue to live the dream I want to
finish the story
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Andre Astarte asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I also love to know which
of TI is top ten rules had the biggest
impact on you why what what are you
going to change now in your business or
life because of watching this video
finally what they give a quick shout out
to Jason Han Jason thank you so much for
purchasing the copy of my book if you
want a chance at a shout out in a future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book and email in your receipts so we
can keep track thank you guys so much
for watching you need to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you soon
that one thing about me man I ain't
sensitive slidin ahead they walk around
man with all this mad baggage man I
ain't sensitive
I understand that thing happy like you
know life answers let's say your [ __ ] we
walk into the room and you know I'm
walking by passing by saying hey
speaking everybody who I see and then
somebody standing right there he speak
to be I had my hand now he and he shake
my hand yeah we beefing up really does
he must not like me man I don't need no
you I didn't see you champ wow I got
bigger fish to fry man